this video explains some of the finer
points for trap crop planting and
maintenance suitable for small farms for
details about basic principles and
effective layouts of mixed trap crops
please see videos part one and two
trap crops are not the silver bullet
solution to all pests while this video
explains planting method for nk 300
sorghum and prodovic sunflower for
leaffooted extinct bug management
research continues on finding most
suitable trap crops and varieties for
reducing other major pests of vegetables
like cucumber beetles and aphids
in the case of sorghum and sunflower
trap crops the sea head is the
attractive plant part in each case in
order to synchronize the availability of
the sea head with the occurrence of the
inset these trap crops should be planted
two weeks earlier than the main crop
small farmers can stagger plant with
multiple rows of trap crops sunflowers
take 70 days while sorghum takes about
100 days to mature
sorghum and sunflower trap crops should
be planted in april and may on good
quality soil planting the trap crop
seeds with the garden push type planter
is an easy process for sorghum we have
observed two plants per foot to be
adequate plant density and function as a
trap crop rose can be planted three or
more feet apart depending on the
available area
side dressing nitrogen for sorghum will
promote rapid growth of the trap crop
some trap crops can have poor
germination with too little soil
moisture
in alabama research running a drip tape
between sorghum rose worked really well
for this hardly low maintenance trap
crop
sunflowers also do well with irrigation
and should be planted on the outside to
arrest early season leaf-footed bug
migration
tomatoes and other main crops should be
planted as far from sorghum mk 300 as
possible to reduce shading
extra space is also necessary for
operating small foreign machinery like
tillers and sprayers between the rows
a trap cropping system is designed to
arrest leaf-footed bug migration and
large numbers will gather on sunflower
and sorghum heads keep a detailed record
of numbers by scouting the insects on a
minimum of 20 heads of the crop and
check the insect count on main crop as
well this would be useful for targeting
insecticide sprays on sorghum
target pests must be removed from the
sorghum trap crop to prevent large
build-up and migration to the main crop
one or two insecticide treatments with
synthetic pyrethroids like warrior and
mustang max are sufficient in
conventional farming systems organic
producers should target enemies with
approved products destroy the trout
crops at the end of the season to
prevent pest carryover
please attend a regional extension
meeting to get new information on
integrated pest management and crop
production methods you can also
attend extension field days for hands-on
integrated pest management training
please contact a regional extension
agent at your local county office today